it is my honor to introduce the greatest
bodybuilder on the planet the recipient
of the 2017 iconic Sandow trophy the
seven-time
[Applause]
we are sitting with the number one let
me say it again being number one body
builder in the world
seven years in a row according to mr.
Olympia he's won it seven times soon to
be eight this is the number one guy
seven billion people in the world lots
of people in the bodybuilding world
there's only one person that can be
number one he's number one Phil Heath
the gift brother thank you for taking
the time for being here with us I've
been looking forward to this really I
got a lot of questions I'm curious what
is your playlist when you workout do you
do you listen to like shot day do you
listen to the Kenny G or is it hit him
up by Tupac what are you listening to
when you're working out well it
definitely is going to differ if I'm
doing cardio or a crazy leg day
interesting because you know when you're
doing cardio you know you might for me I
might be doing like some audiobooks or
stuff like that just the past time and
actually try to learn something when
you're doing legs and I use legs and
this is a big example because who really
likes doing it we all know that it
requires a lot of focus a lot of drive
and determination and we also know that
you could potentially get sick gets
people go really hard on that
I always listen to heavy metal for me
and you have it and you hit it on the
head with two pockets it's like you got
to have something that's very intense
the words have to be meaningful I don't
really get into the New Age of hip-hop
mm-hmm because I can't really understand
everything they're saying all the time I
feel like I'm an old guy so true though
right
I'm old school you know I'm still
listening to NWA I'm still listening to
Dawg like his first album I'm still
listening to jay-z I still listen to NAS
I still do all that but when I'm really
trying to get after I usually have my
playlist I can give it to you right now
I usually have Five Finger Death Punch I
usually have ac/dc I'll have dr. Dre
Tupac hit him up is for sure I mean
there's so many tiers by Tupac Wow I'd
say Snoop Dogg Who am I you know the one
he says what's my name that probably is
my most favorite song of all time I
could be having the crappiest workout or
even the worst
I put that on and nothing else matters
I'm like because it's like saying Who am
I like who are you like what are you
here for what are you doing the gym is
the only place where you can essentially
be yourself for one hour or two you
don't have to answer the phone you don't
have to really communicate with anybody
but those weights those machines and
that's like my time so it's like you put
that song on and nothing else matters
and I think that's why I identify with
more old-school hip-hop I mean I could
throw an ice cube no Vaseline like I get
to go way back like like that like
because it's like a point in time in my
life when I was a teenager when I
remember hearing this and it just got me
going I can listen to Public Enemy you
know fight the power like I mean how do
you not if you hear that song you guys
listen to that song and you're staring
at 500 pounds on the squad you know that
you got to go after you know that you
got to go give maximum effort and that's
what I do in the gym so feel before we
get into some of the questions did you
one day wake up and just say from you
know eight years old I'm gonna be mister
all empty I'm gonna be the you know
bodybuilder seven times I'm gonna be
there so how did that process take place
from you going to where you are today
quite the opposite I grew up in Seattle
Washington my biggest thing was
basketball growing up watching I mean
gosh I had the best childhood got to see
the end of dr. Jay Bernard King too like
Larry Bird Magic Johnson Isiah Thomas
this guy named Michael Jordan you know
alright you know and really get to see
like real competitive basketball that
was what I was into I was always into
that but I do remember watching a lot of
ESPN you know and then every so often
you would see a bodybuilding show on
ESPN and that's when they used to even
showcase like the Junior Nationals this
is amateur competitions they would
actually put on like a Saturday
afternoon
you know they had already pre-recorded
it and stuff like that we're seeing this
stuff right as you say that I remember
that and I'm like what's what's this a
night but here's the thing I never
thought that it was weird I never
thought anything negative I thought
comic book heroes on a stage and I
didn't know the names of those
competitors at the
time but I did know who source and anger
was because at that time in the 80s and
90s he was polarized everywhere you know
with movies and stuff like that and
obviously Lou Ferrigno because the Hulk
and all that so I always gravitated
toward muscles even though I was playing
basketball and in high school being at
that's my player people used to make fun
of me all the time because they're like
dude you should be playing football cuz
you're already kind of built for that so
you were bad guy you always built now
were you training all know I didn't lift
weights they don't just just you know
just regular stuff we call the Herschel
Walker workout push-ups sit-ups squats
air squats that's it and that's what I
did
where Shaquille O'Neal said oh you want
to get a bigger calf development be able
to jump higher you got to do you know if
you live in a house that has stairs do
calf raises just do calf raises you
can't do the war that's why every night
I was like well I wasn't blessed to be
tall but I could outrun him and I could
try to elevate so I learned at an early
age that some type of physical fitness
was important and that was back in the
day when Shore singer was with George
Bush doing the President's Council on
health and fitness there's challenges
and stuff that were available in
elementary school that was a big deal
and where I grew up I grew up in South
Seattle where we had you know myself we
have you know a lot of different
Division one athletes that turned pro in
various sports and we all grew up in
that same area went to that same
elementary school so you're dealing with
really good athletes trying to do the
flexed arm hang or pull-ups or a shuttle
run I thought it was great and that's
back in the day when Phil day was like
something special so I can say that
although I didn't grow up aspiring to be
a mr. Olympia I always aspired to be
healthy and strong and tried to use that
in basketball because I knew that I was
not blessed to be tall I didn't have the
longest honor I've read and heard things
that you would do to windmill dunk at a
young age
we're already high you had a vertical
leap I don't know what number was but
yeah my junior year at the University of
Denver we you know you test in and stand
still vertical was at 40 so Stan state
stands still so it worked
because I'm just under 510 so you know
coach gonna take a chance on a guy
that's under six foot they can't elevate
to the basket or even get a shot off
because he
can jump high it definitely enabled me
to earn a division 1 scholarship
I didn't play a whole lot but you know
at the end of the day I was able to you
know get a pretty good set of degrees
you know with IT in business so that
worked out well and actually promoted me
into doing bodybuilding and I think
what's cool about you is a lot of times
you know in the in the world of
bodybuilding you know people see
somebody with a lot of muscles and they
say he's probably just big and he's not
very smart and insightful and all this
other stuff you've heard this before me
and all these offers you're probably one
of the sharpest cats out there you know
in your world and you represent the
industry in a way where somebody's
sitting there saying I got a four-year
degree I did school and I got stuff
maybe I ought to consider this guys
thinking about it I want to consider as
well so you know from there did you like
it were you was it a dream to go become
an NBA player or was just kind of
something you did did you say what do I
like to play with that thought I still
remember it I was a junior in high
school playing really well
averaging quite a bit and then we had
this transfer come in by the name of
Jamal Crawford Wow
so you saw on your team on my team well
you played which what we wouldn't state
together that following year so here I
am knowing that like they were it was
already in the Seattle Times like watch
out for Heath next year he's gonna
probably leave be one of the leaders in
scoring in the state now might get that
sounds cool until this guy comes in and
he's a pro already you know it right off
the bat when you play with though the
guy was torching guys in summer league
you know the guys playing against grown
man putting up 50 points and pickup
games on these guys I mean it was like
no joke the attention to detail that
Jamal had I had with school and other
things in life and we shared that and
watch being able to play with you know
with him against him in practice taught
me a lot taught me that I probably
wasn't gonna go pro and I should
probably go to a university that has a
great education and so that's why you
identified it right right there well you
know annoying compete if I I knew that I
knew what I was up against I mean it's
clear as day when you're getting a stack
of letters this big and he's got a full
Melvin so it doesn't mean that I suck
just means that he's exceptionally well
at what his guy
given talent is and he's and he's
putting everything into that I on the
other hand should recognize what I'm
also good at and stop trying to live
vicariously through you know I'm saying
thinking I'm the same as him I thought I
was the same as him I'm not six four
four six five I don't have long limbs I
don't have the same handle as him I
don't look like him so I drew it out
like this I said okay let's just say
best-case scenario this all works out
you go play ball you do that they fill
your five ten probably by the time
you're twenty eight twenty nine years
old your career is over now guess what
the people that you graduated with or
six years into their professional you
you're going to be working for them
you're gonna now work for them when you
were just as smart as them earlier no
one person is alone you're right I mean
it's not you know you said it recently
you said uh twenty years ago if you had
a contract you at least had a hundred
thousand dollar contract by somebody
supplement companies today you know
there are thousands of supplement
companies and all they care about is
themselves they don't want to give
contracts today no it's tougher today
than it was twenty years ago a million
times time even twenty years ago wasn't
that big twenty years I know you have to
be you know the greatest yeah it to even
compete in the world yes
so that it did the doc go to a point
where you're a pretty confident guy yes
you know I mean some people will even
say maybe pass confident but only it's
not somebody that doesn't have
self-confidence right so did you say you
know what I think i can go into
bodybuilding and I think I can compete
for the top spot I knew that I was at a
point in time where I was getting ready
to graduate
cuz I play four years straight and then
my fifth year I was finishing up school
and that's when I got into bodybuilding
and then I just start running into guys
in class like this guy was smelling like
tuna broccoli all the time like what the
hell is this and who are these people on
your laptop man at the time we're
talking about 2002 2003 I got Brooke
Burke on my wallpaper on my laptop right
you know I'm saying she was fine yeah I
got her all my stuff you got these dudes
in these poses choice tell me more about
it so he tells you about it I'm like oh
I heard of this flex wheeler dude I
heard about this Kevin Brody guy that
big-ass dude oh so much yes sir
not well him too but Ronnie combs
money because he was the champ at the
time so I'm asking him about this and
you want to learn more man come to the
don't go to the varsity great room where
you know your athletes going don't go to
the public weight room go to publicize
getting after man this is pretty cool
strong cats in here so I just started
started training with them next to you
know I started supporting them going to
their competitions yeah
ran into a couple pros that kind of
recommended that I should give it a try
one guy by the name of quad rule here
just won the Masters in Libya and he had
said I should give it a go on October 8
2002 is when I said okay you're gonna
become a bodybuilder no more basketball
that's it decision took a picture with
my tracksuit just the bottoms did a
little pose with a 2.1 megapixel camera
took that picture and said this is my
starting point and after that I took a
picture every week of my progress I just
figure will read books about nutrition
read books about training by flex
magazine muscle fitness you'll learn and
then take the pictures because at that
time body for life was a big deal 3 a
yes yes his magazine was muscle media mm
yeah it's my favorite magazine yeah I
was cuz they actually got deep into it
and as a matter of fact that's how I was
able to prove that I really wanted to be
a bodybuilder you know when a basketball
player a basketball player will go great
lengths to go find a court so for
bodybuilding it wasn't necessarily I was
breaking into gyms late night I worked
at a fairly total fitness I was a retail
manager instead of going to IT world I
did this you worked at Bally's I worked
at Bally's office a good deal helping
people with Nutritionals making
smoothies people were like dude you guys
you guys should be working back behind
here and you know it's funny a lot of
people laughed they're like yeah making
my smoothie dude this and that the other
just trying to just talk down to me and
I'm thinking to myself these guys have
no idea one guy in line was seeing me
get harassed by someone that I guess I
didn't fill up their shake all the way
to the top and she was just going off
and I just said you know it's being nice
I just said you know I'll make another
one for you on my apologies here's a
card
we'll get you another free one on your
next visit no problem oh you're just an
idiot and this and that and the guy says
actually that guy that you call an idiot
was a Division one basketball at the
University
where you got two degrees that is a and
then she and then another guy goes with
it why is he working here and that's
when I said you know I probably
shouldn't cert myself at this
conversation and I said how are you off
31 years old I said oh that's good
where'd you go to school I said well
that's right you didn't go to D you
you're giving me a hard time trying to
posture based on what my job title to
this little do you realize I treat this
store as if in my own
I'm giving free education on how to run
a business I do all the hiring firing I
do all the payroll I do all the ordering
I meet with all the distributors all the
manufacturers that you know for the
supplement companies and whatnot I know
what comes in I know what comes out I
know the planograms I organize all these
things I know the profit margins are not
only third-party nutritionals but also
Valley nutritionals to keep these lights
on so I know profit and loss and I can
do a whole P&L analysis I know all this
stuff
I know operations and I actually use
that from my degree so at some point in
time don't you think it 23 years old
maybe I get a little older and I learned
that maybe I can do this on my own but
I'm getting free education with this if
there's kids that work at jobs you know
it could be anywhere fast-food
restaurants that's net there is just a
job it's just a gig they don't really
care other ones will say there's some
real business into this man I want to
learn like how my little store can outdo
every store in the state not just in
quota but in profit margin because
that's what matters that keep the lights
on I tell people this when you become a
professional in anything the level of
magnification is greater than when
you're in amateur imagine my picture
being on a slide you're doing this as an
amateur magnification maybe 10 times Pro
50 times top Pro hundred times mr.
Olympia 250 time and then first split
you know seven years in a row
500 ton ride right because it's all
about the negative at that point now as
an athlete let's be honest man athletes
I don't care what people say they want
to be loved man they want to be
appreciated we're being adjudicated by
my judges based on what they feel is
right and maybe it's their own personal
preference to along these guidelines so
your your training essentially hoping
that they like you so
I treat life like a leg day who wants to
train arms to Phil Heath people line up
around the corner chest to lines around
the corner legs I don't know man see
tomorrow may have five people out of a
hundred because they know it's gonna be
painful they it's unexpected it's the
most uncomfortable situation you're
gonna be in who likes to be
uncomfortable as an athlete you realize
like this is a game so like you said Ted
Williams Usain Bolt all those guys they
would they would hear trash talk and
this and then they're like okay all
right now let's go do it
do you intentionally create it because
there's you topside you're at your [ __ ]
table everybody knows you are seduced do
you also kind of do it to get the other
guys right there's two reasons well
there's multiple reasons right number
one you're trying to sell
I don't did this Phil he's getting a
portion of the ticket says no but let's
be real what people are so-called tired
of a champ
being a champ this and that I don't want
you in hiding talking this trash I want
you to say it to my face but you won't
say it to my face because you know my
mentality
you know that I'm gonna absorb that I'm
gonna embrace that not gonna use that
fuel better than they do
you obviously are not ty Makai green I
mean you're nothing for him I mean he
and I had a great moment he chose to
choose different pastures hey fun things
I always have to come on in move on the
other guys personally I think there is
respect and here's my thing I would tell
a lot of them get my cell phone number
you could text me and be like hey Phil
love you dude you're the big bro you're
you're the key but I'm coming to kick
your ass man who has said that you who
has that the audacity so and so then
here's a question for you do you think
it helps to know that there's not a
definite number to that can really
compete with you today so for instance
as a plan some are sitting there saying
here's the Vegas odds to bet bro you got
number one everyone knows who's gonna
win number one you have everybody else
why they help bet on anything cuz no
one's gonna win first place yeah do you
think that's good for the sport I'm just
gonna be real what they should do this
is what the athletes should do
second place has been shifted from
vegetation to Shawn Rhoden to
yeah so what they should do those guys
who start talking [ __ ] to each other
they should be saying that's the word
the robbery is there's some inner
robberies within every league it doesn't
always have to be the top team and the
second-place team it could be other
teams or other individuals if you're
always trying to come after me why not
make it a three-headed monster coming
after Phil Heath the top five this and
then it explained you would tell them to
team up and you know try to compete
against each other so strengthen each
other then somebody can cook me anyway
they're trying to be too realistic they
can anybody beat you
I guess realistically yeah I mean I can
get injured god forbid - you don't -
that hell you take care of yourself
pretty good no I mean your discipline is
not like you're partying Friday night
down at the Deborah nightclub things
happen I mean I've won last year with
two hernias and an intestinal
strangulation problem and I still want
so this is the part I'm with Cuban and I
asked Cuban a question I said mark look
at the Golden State Warriors and they're
killing it says Pat don't get too
excited
says the Warriors are one ankle injury
away from not even making it to the
Western Conference Finals he said this
to me right and I'm like you know what I
never thought about it but if there is
no injured if there is no injury that's
anybody stand a chance no because I was
hurt all the last four years and didn't
address you know I mean who doesn't
address a hernia I mean gosh like you
know it wasn't as bad I didn't feel it
and you know it wasn't hindering
performance so I was like oh well no big
deal and then I started seeing it and I
was like oh this is a problem and then
realizing that after the surgery was
over supposed to be a 15 minute 25
minute surgery it took two hours so
therefore how long was recovery now I
mean I got a dinner after your Olympia
so now I'm you know as a January 1st you
know here we are in February I've been
able to train so this last six weeks so
in September till today you haven't hit
the weights
well September - to Jen when December
laughs yeah and the bedroom so so you're
saying they may have a chance this year
come watch because it could they could
actually have a shot actually no I guess
yeah I'm with you I'm on your well the
reason why I would say no is because in
layman's terms when you go through and
hernia and you have to and
you have an intentional strangulation
issue that means that it cuts off the
blood supply to certain vital organs
therefore your body can't renew its own
blood supply to feed those proper organs
which in fact would feed those cells
that actually make your muscles more
volumize so if I'm already interesting
so in bodybuilding we want our muscles
to be shredded also separated but also
volumize big round cartoonish my body
hasn't been very cartoonish over the
last three four years because it's
gotten progressively worse but now since
that's been taken care of I can go by
pictures I can go by blood work I can go
by you know what my doctor has showed me
and then I can go by physical
performance I've been able to just over
the past month do exercises that I can't
I couldn't have done five six years ago
without pain so what is that gonna yield
it's probably gonna mean that like the
blood supply is now renewing itself
because it usually takes anywhere from
56 to 90 days for that body to real rest
you know how they said something good to
take a week so this is actually like
I've been winning with the problem ever
anyway yeah and now it's gone
so yes yeah man is was already betting
before it's like well hell he was
beating you guys with 50% his abdominal
core he was able to beat you so at 98%
cuz that's where I'm at right now that's
according to an idea but the doctor said
he said I sewed you up to where you're
98% when you're retired we'll have to go
in there and redo everything you have a
scar I couldn't Rock a scar on stage you
don't have a scar I have no scar at all
you can't rock or the scar no not in
your world not mine were like a
professional and mr. Olympia tattoos
don't help don't really help so I guess
the competition has probably been quiet
because they're waiting to see what I
look like just offseason because like
wait a minute like what's he gonna look
like I think social media has changed
your world and this is what I mean by
change your world I think sometimes when
the money comes too early your fire goes
away I'm an 18 year old kid okay I've
been lifting weights I get on a cycle
and I start looking guy get on another
cycle
now I'm looking good Instagram I start
putting pictures and I'm doing all this
other stuff right now I'm like a decent
you know half decent good-looking guy
now I have eight hundred twenty thousand
people
now I got one point eight million people
follow me right and I got a supplement
company comes and says I'll pay fifty
thousand dollars up thirty sixty
thousand dollars I've paid thirty
thousand dollars I give you $100,000
contract now making 300 grand Europe I'm
going to the clubs I'm getting all the
play but I don't have to put your work
ethic in you know what screw it I don't
want to be mr. Olympia
that's cross stop so do you think social
media is helping or hurting mr. oh not
not the other side your mr. oh I think
it's to the point where maybe not the
champion of mr. Libya but the other guys
so if you took an 18 year old kid
nowadays they have a hard choice to make
they want to be YouTube or they want to
be an athlete
there ain't both in my opinion because
so either because when you're doing
skits you're doing a skin did Kobe
Bryant do a skit LeBron James do a skit
Michael Jordan do a skit yo they were
too busy in the gym doing their crafts
the difference is in basketball you
can't make money there is no like you
know what I'm saying like yeah so what
body but leading it's like what is your
main goal man you just want to be liked
because let's be real you take down
social media you take down the internet
I would be a god because I mean what
would they go by go by the statues they
go by the trophies they go by the
accolades as what people want you take
away any type of social media in all
sports you're gonna go by or who's the
champion who's the best not the who's
the best on YouTube is this that I'm not
gonna sit here and discredit anyone that
has made a living off of social media
because at the end of the day they're
content creators great he'll send me
your business card maybe you could
create some content for me
but that same time perfect example why
wouldn't kinda green to continually
compete people say oh he's afraid that's
net no he's not he realizes that it's
probably better for him to create more
content focusing on commerce he could
create content and look just as popular
cuz now in his heart does he feel like
it's more popular maybe he does maybe he
does it but he knows he's not mr. Limpy
we're old school these kids they just
think like the loudest person in the
room is the most valid we're also trying
to learn these algorithms and all other
stuff hey I'm an IT guy I get this world
it is very difficult to kind of figure
out this social experiment but it is
fairly easy to make money today it is
but then you just become just like the
next guy what your Crazy Eights to all
the youtubers
all the Instagram models all these girls
that are holding up tea
than any other yeah what is the
difference you show your glutes more
your butt more your boobs more a guy
shows the B it is free yeah I think it
pictures into the public bathroom yeah
mr. Libby doesn't take pictures of the
public bathroom to get noticed this is
art this is thoughts of determination
lots of strange mental physical
emotional strength now if they think
that they could cross over into my world
they got another thing coming because I
can easily cross over there there's
there's the difference so if we're
talking about like how do I try to
influence other kids it's like we'll
look you're trying to be a bodybuilder
but don't want to clean it and I think
that's sad because you're trying to do
the thing same things as a bodybuilder
in this that you don't want to claim it
why you don't think it's cool enough oh
you don't want to be judged you want to
you want to live in the society where
it's on it's through the third person
you can edit everything Photoshop do you
live in a virtual world and that's what
people live in so this is my opinion
about your world I think your brand is
missing one thing
and I think it's missing a Dana White I
truly believe that Oh I truly do need a
Dana White that comes in you need
someone to make this larger than life I
really believe that height the forces
there people's no I think if I'm in that
world and if I want that tradition to
continue because if you don't change
something right now the next 20 years it
may be a different story I would go look
for my Dana White I'd give him a
shitload of equity a 9% type of a number
and I'm not I'm not promoting anybody I
don't know anybody that would be it
would need to be somebody from your
world that actually like a Rogan who
knew that world and bright they brought
him and they brought Dana because he was
in a pride or a belt or whatever was
that he was a part of I think you guys
need a promoter because I think that
brand you mr. Olympia needs to come up
and so how do you do that maybe the
person's got to get high right now it's
a 450 yeah I think what needs to happen
I agree I think we have Schwarzenegger
who's great he's a great promoter yeah
right so and then we just recently had
Dwayne Johnson and his production
company seven bucks productions work
with the Olympia brand doing the
production and we're not i do believe
those two people in order to make this
grow exponential not only have to speak
more about our brand but use those
corporate partnerships and show videos
like this of showing athletes stories
and let people know that we're not dumb
maybe some maybe some we dispel a lot of
negative stereotypes and I don't care
who you are what sport you love anytime
there is a sign of strength of
accomplishment and achievement they all
pose like a bodybuilder they all pose
boxers they do the faceoff they pose
that's right Rampal the Brawn pose if he
Duncan come on green if someone gets a
tan when they pose a running back run
someone over he poses a linebacker
crushes the quarterback he posts right
where the hell are you learning this
from that's right
Christiano Ronaldo hit a goal he's
taking his shirt off flexing where you
learned this from we deserve the respect
I'm with you he deserve the respect but
here's the thing does the world not
understand that bodybuilders eat six
seven times a day the shoes that we wear
the socks that we wear the clothing the
wrist wraps there's more commerce in our
sport you actually need a elbow sleeve
there's an elbow sleeve necessary for a
basketball player all the time it's more
fashion bodybuilders need elbow sleeves
knee sleeves headbands this and that we
need all that stuff out of business are
you kidding me
beats by dre should have been talking to
guys like me or whoever I've been
working with a headphone company but
this should have been happening years
ago because what does a bodybuilder do
he has to have music to trade to keep
himself motivated we need proper food
proper sleep so we're talking about
mattress companies does capitalism at
its best Nike should be calling me up
saying but that's I know I don't think
that's how it works no but exactly I
don't think I think I think you guys
need a guy that's thinking what you're
saying right now I agree because here's
a couple thoughts let's just say I'm in
your world right I'm hired to be in your
world here's what I'm doing number one
the purse cannot be form on a grant it
has not one of you I want it I wanted
more if we imagine if your first place
is getting a 10 million dollar contract
second place is a five million dollar
shirt you were going to want to
now here's another part here's another
part what if mr. Olympia is being shown
on TV back then apps we're doing a TV
ending you do panels Lily and I can get
this whole thing work force it down
their throat what if I go out there and
start doing more movies think about like
even a small movie do you remember the
movie do you remember that scene this
kid wants to be who flex with those
small little comments how many people
know flex we love to know the world but
those little things there should we
gotta promote it man oh I should have
been an entourage they'd be in the gym
they could have had me as a cameo fit so
that's one but well right now I don't
have one WME representing you but but
that's where Mark in the back he's got
all that man but he gonna bring the
mobsters have but here's the best part
about that sometimes though man here's
the best part about it is that not a lot
of people and I and I appreciate this
dialogue I don't get to have this
exchange rate often I don't think that
the outside world thinks that people
like me want that because I've spoken to
people outside I speak in spoken to
sales guys with fortune five missing
that CMO CEOs this night you know what
they all say is like I don't want to
bother you I couldn't imagine bothering
you with something like this because
they're thinking like well he has to eat
sleep and train to look like that
because they're putting themselves into
that here's the thing I would say to
them all elite of the elite have hobbies
Michael Jordan would go hit 18 to 36
holes during that 92 Olympics lots of
you know a lot of hobbies for some
reason the best of the best have hobbies
away from their hobby so find out what
those are and realize that if someone
said hey Phil I want you to come do like
a free-throw shooting contest with kids
and stuff like that it kind of look
funny because you're a big guy I said
I'd do it just to have fun with it I
could do a plenty of different failings
you need a W so and and again I you need
there needs to be a collaboration with
you and rock you and Kevin Hart you and
these guys if if I'm working behind the
scenes I need you to be on Kevin Hart's
platform with 56-million about what we
bring in Kevin Hart to our I just booked
them
sanatory event in august to conform in
vegas you need to do something with rock
and he nice opposed it on his thing
those collaborative so you're the number
one guy right now right sorry so i think
what's happening now especially with
Dwayne and his brand is that they are
participating in our world and that it
has to because he's a fan right so he
loves working out yes I appreciate their
work I do also recognize he's probably
the most busiest guy in Hollywood these
guys doing way too much eating had no
time
so I appreciate any time he's willing to
give but I also think that there's other
people like you said back in the day
when P we still go to mr. Olympia we
used to get like guys like Gregory Hines
there we used to get like real
celebrities you know like there where
are they right now we need to get them
in because every actor wants to get buff
they don't necessarily want to be mr.
Olympia but they want to get stronger
they're hitting up trainers you know
this and that to go do their diets and
stuff but here's the best part it was
funny to me that I was my fiancee she's
great she had me watching this the
Kardashians right so said what am I
watching this for she's like oh well Kim
got a trainer said oh cool Kim in hired
this lady to get her off of the foods
that she was doing and stuff like that
so I like this is Lady I'm like wow she
lost a lot of weight miss man she was
even like competitive you know
bodybuilding and stuff like that so I
was like wow that's really neat and I
gave him a lot of credit whoever was
managing this ordeal because I'm
thinking she took it upon herself to go
find somebody that his lost weight and
his female but has more of an extreme
side to her because that's what she
needed she needed extreme change why
aren't more athletes why are more you
know celebrities calling up best
bodybuilders in the world say it hey man
love your stuff dude do you mind flying
out during offseason I just love to
spend a week with you I'd be all for it
I would do that throughout my whole
offseason you know why because I'd be
helping people out and presenting myself
to them and then they'd probably be like
man I feel youth man man he's a cool
dude man I we had so many similarity
that's not hard to fill no I don't think
that's art so let me let me ask you a
question I don't know the answer to this
who is the Commissioner mr. Olympia
right now Mike who is blaze David picker
owns America media which almost say
Olympia brand
our president of the International
Federation of bodybuilders is Jim
Mannion that's who that's who runs it if
you're a big promoter is your big
marketer is your big yeah so you need
the you need David David is mr. pecker
is the one that is in charge of all that
because he owns the brand itself it
would be it would be so it would be
three honestly it would be three things
I would do like this it get instant
media and it bring more attention back
to it I'd go to a couple corporate
sponsors that are gonna be making I'd go
have conversations with three of these
health brands Under Armour Nike some of
these guys sit down and say here's what
we're looking at why don't we sponsor
and increase the purse if we increase
the purse this is what's gonna happen
let's sign attend your contract these
things are out there for some other
negotiate this contract is not like it's
not out there and it know you're I mean
you're hitting it I mean I would love to
sit on those conversations as well
because I would love to hear the yes or
the no you know you know what could
possibly happen here's what could
possibly happen and then we'll wrap up
with the last topic this is a prediction
this is a prediction I'm making I'm not
no Nostradamus but this is a prediction
who is the biggest promoter and
bodybuilding name that is a Hollywood
yeah yeah now governor okay watch what I
think could possibly happen you already
know where I'm going with this okay I
think if mr. Oh David these guys are
talking about if they don't do a better
job promoting what they're promoting
fast forward 10 20 years because he's
going to that thing could end up
becoming just as big as mr. ol if Arnold
Classic starts becoming that because
he's going to promote now I think I
think with that I think with what's
stronger with the mr. Olympia is that
that's who Arnold is we're not arm
sourcing harness where's my gear is mr.
Olympia and so therefore the mr. Olympia
show will outshine anything no matter
how much promotion how to promote it
bill I agree I mean I do but I will say
this in defense of what's going on I I
do like to changes recently by saying
you know what who do we know oh man we
know Dwayne Johnson okay well let's
invite him out to our shows see if he
finds this even worth his while seven
bucks production says let's do something
and I have been
told that like we're gonna be
continually doing more that's all so I
can only be patient the enthusiasm that
we're having through this dialogue is
great I've truly believe that that's
what they want because the group that
they have are into working out that some
of them have competed so they recognize
like this needs to be showcased you and
I are the same we want it today let's do
it now let's do this take a while and I
do recognize this gonna take a while
however what I would personally like is
just have me sit down I should be
sitting at that table because I'm not
some box of rocks stone his meat head
this new no no I I deserve to be at the
table and not just to say like oh this
is how it benefits Phil Heath is this is
how it benefits when I'm gone because I
truly believe that a lot of bodybuilders
both men and women and all categories
have a great story to tell we can't just
rely on them to use their voice through
social media because it should also come
from a major platform we should be
contributing to okay we have a
federation let's let's work with
Federation let's work with like saying
like hey let's do some collaborative
efforts and showing that this is what
cuz that's what they're selling yeah I'm
not selling the athlete well they're
selling the organization and they're
selling the the shows within the
organization question I was briefly in
the world to just kind of go in and I
would go see everybody I remember when
Greg Kovac was there Mike matera so you
know like these guys like Bill Phillips
wrote his book was it body for like this
one that he wrote do you think a part of
it maybe that there needs to be
education done on steroids growth
hormone PD because maybe there's a fear
of well if we go to this point you know
and there's a regulation comes in and
says you can't be doing this you can't
be doing that you know like it happened
with baseball then it may get a black
guy so it's better we stay the way we
are right now let's not get into the
national attention do you think there's
a little bit of that concern on the
people involved that they don't want to
get into a deep with that topic cuz you
know there is the on-camera answer
there's the off-camera conversation well
there it comes down to the simple point
where you know every athlete has a
choice they want to make with their own
body it is what it is and make it Surfer
rewards but also consequences they're
there there are those everybody's
perception is going to be such but we've
also
the arguments of like if bo Jackson was
playing today would he be considered
this this and this they would say yes
but then you know so there are genetic
freaks and everything I do think that
what needs to take place is people need
to just realize that these are
professional athletes no different than
any Olympic athletes have we seen
they're all they're all pretty much
lumped in this category what I would be
focusing on is what they're able to do
in their daily life with their ability
to take the discipline that they have
living the life that they normally live
because people are competing because
they don't make enough money people
actually have normal jobs like some of
these women they have like 3 4 KS and
it's in that if we were talking about
like the triumphs and all other stuff
people like these stories people need
these stories we watched 34 30s all the
time we watched each 60s all the time
based on triumphs there's a lot of
triumph within the sport so whether you
want to talk about PDS or whatever it is
that's not even a question
but the question I have is is why aren't
these stories being told about people of
triumph and and how they were able to
focus with all the world's problems that
going against them and focus solely on
their physique and understanding like
these people are able to diagnose self
diagnose every little thing that's going
on in their body to look a certain way
for a certain period of time I think we
should be sending those people down and
saying please teach me how were you able
to gain this much muscle or how are you
able to keep your liver and kidneys and
this and that what does this diet mean
why aren't you guys doing these fad
diets but the society has this being
told that we need to do this vegan paleo
all this other stuff when you don't have
to do this let's let's have this
conversations because we are the guinea
pigs for society when it comes to health
and wellness we understand that if I go
out and eat a sweet potato or baked
potato or red potato or a yellow potato
we know the damn difference the outside
people don't even know what that is and
we have all that knowledge and people
want to focus on peds all the time I
don't know I thought to do is they need
to realize that there are so many other
permutations of diet and exercise it's
just crazy I don't think that's where
I'm going with it I think where I'm
going with it is the following so you
said something whose show were you on
you're on the gap from hangover what is
that guy's name is
Brian Cameron dishon on his podcasts or
sound like that and then they showed a
picture of Tiger Woods right on Anna you
said something very interesting you said
you know what you know what Tiger should
have done Tiger sure came out and said
look here's what I did I messed up but I
thought that I know here's where I'm at
with this park and if people would have
forgot about and I agree not believe me
when he said that stay message you know
what the guy makes a good point
that's how you should come out even your
I think your follower of Tim Grover I
think your app letting you know you said
Tiger should've came in a different way
to see this is who I am what do you me
to do I'm a freakin cleaner this is how
I'm wired
I can't change my wiring right right so
football kept saying let's not look at
CT nets Nauticus CT let's not look at CT
let's not look a CT Oh Will Smith oh
then it's like oh my gosh they could
have done a complete different way I
like what Adam Silver is doing Adam
Silver is kind of getting ahead of
everything we're hey I think it's very
progressive on the approach he's taken
and then you mercy with marijuana I mean
we're in Colorado right now you know you
gotta have the conversation what is it
what should we do this and so they came
out and started talking about the real
challenges with it I think I think the
bodybuilding would just come out and say
and talk about it and say listen let me
explain to the level average
testosterone level for 25 year old for
30 or 35 year old 40 or 45 year old this
is not anything more than I am eating
this to produce this I am eating this to
produce [ __ ] if you do this it helps
you sustain this level helps of immune
system the challenges are this and you
need to know this and this Angus you
think there's a part of it were on the
bodybuilding side mister o or Arnold
Arnold came out and he talked about a
little bit more openly I did this I did
this with my blood and all this other
stuff do you think there's an
opportunity to kind of come out and say
look you know if we want to compete at
this level and this is what the market
does this is what we do but in order to
do it we have this levels and we do this
to take care of our bodies and our
health and this is what you don't want
to do because you saw what happened with
this other guy that just passed away do
you think there's an opportunity for
education with it I think there's a
education of everything with that but
the problem is is that everybody is
different so everybody's gonna have a
different story and the problem is is
that everybody thinks that what one
person is doing everybody's doing and
that's the problem is that one person is
going to be speaking for everybody it's
going to be the extreme it is because
that's wouldn't that be education so for
instance we
wouldn't have a channel but that would
take so long like think about it like
okay so you're gonna line up 500 people
and give them the same type of blood
work you miss it now and then and then
actually the the problem is is this the
average person isn't going to believe
anything a person says they're just not
because if someone says well I had heard
this person did this this person said he
did this and you're telling me you don't
and a persist yes I'm not there like
you're lying and it's like well the
discussion over dude because honestly I
can show you pictures like for me I can
show people pictures of what I look like
at 13 years old it's not yeah this isn't
about me it's just about like the
perception of like having these
conversations I see where you're coming
at it's I simply saying there's a big
misconception there's a big sheriff and
I think that that should not dis that
should not disallow any corporate
sponsor to be involved in this sport
because of the simple fact that look
there are some amazing athletes there
they're able to do incredible things the
determination the drive these are things
that they motivate people I motivate
people from trying to kill themselves
I've motivated people with ailments
beyond measure that make me realize like
this this is more their body than it is
mine
I've won seven mr. Olympia titles and I
could be honest and say those titles are
more for them than for myself at times
when I read these emails when I read
these direct messages and I'm very
fortunate and blessed to have a platform
where I could say you know what the
motivation I give someone I'm just in
their training I'm just hearing a hare
doing minecraft and so that's what my
calling is my calling is you know they
say oh you're the gift what does that
mean I say you know it I have a gift I
used it to the best of my abilities and
I at the point in time in my career
where I wanted to share this with the
world I'm willing to share my
experiences with business with athletic
prowess to where anyone from all walks
of life and women child can understand
like it's a kid that didn't give up talk
about my childhood we talked about high
school in college a lot of wise in a row
to why I'm here today are they perfect
no but I made sure I used every ounce of
resource and determination thank you
today and I'm no different than anybody
else we all have that heart we all have
that brain you just have to have that
confidence and we can be we have to be
unapologetic to be successful your life
is very difficult
yeah your life is very difficult but if
someone else has to tell it because if I
tell it but it looks like very difficult
are you kidding me seven meals a day you
know the heat at night sleep trying to
get a good sleep to you guys is like
heaven and relaxing and not getting a
cold or a flu or a sickness all this
other [ __ ] that comes with it and at the
same time mentally family finance to
come up you don't have any money you got
43 bucks
when you first enter that five grand won
the prior to that you know you know flex
wheeler I think that's your lunch for
you or some some story like that you
ain't any paper those things you know
that people don't hear it is a very
difficult world you're in I respect what
you guys do all I'm coming from is I'm
just coming from a place of saying
here's a brand that's elevated to this
level now we've had some incredible
champions Haney eight times Ronnie
eight times Arnold 7u7 you're about to
do aid you could be the first nine ten
times I'm sure your goal is to the
double-digit and not stop until you to
ten that's a milestone that's gonna be
hard to hit I just think there's a part
of it where there is a education element
to it and I think that education could
be done by professors doctors that are
on both the sides like for me when I
when I when I want to debate politics
someone wants are talking about politics
I always like to have a Democrat a
Republican and guy in the middle think
of it like this when was bodybuilding
very popular we can say when the harness
horse neighbor was doing it right we
could say that right after art was
reported any was doing it what was honor
also doing he was a part of governor
sport a health and fitness president's
council health and fitness guys like me
should be a part of that if you're mr.
Olympia and you're not a part of the
governor's board of health and fitness
where you live or the President's
Council of health and fitness there's a
problem because of the fact that guys I
source Nagar understood lifting they
understood determination you telling me
that I couldn't go to schools around the
country and we store that President's
Council of health and fitness tell no
test they're gonna be like hell yeah
they're the good guys guys well let's do
this and I can show them I'm a
functional athlete as well like why why
isn't that happen
it's Arnold working with you as a flag
carrier like bringing you up to be the
next face of their own there's not a you
guys won't have that kind of
relationship now unfortunately we don't
I would love to have that and I think
you would love to have a because I think
I think it's important because you need
to be able to have someone to pass the
torsion unfortunately in this industry I
mean we're all very busy and I'll give
Arnold that you know he's very extremely
busy man I'll be seeing him next weekend
you know it is classic if I were to have
five minutes with him and literally look
at me in the eye and tell him say look
what is it gonna take I think one thing
you guys could easily have that
conversation but I'm not saying that we
couldn't I'm just saying like he
probably needs to hear it from me and
it's amazing there's a book it's called
true believer okay it's called a true
believer phenomenal book and it talks
about how if you really want to change
something you have to do it by people
that are driven by a true belief not
based on monetary you're a true believer
I mean you're talking like an ambassador
of the world you're in this is why I ask
the question for me I said who's the
president who's the marketer that write
about the flag come on I do feel like I
have value within that I do feel like
they see that I think it now is upon
look sometimes I think it's not those
people that have a problem or anything
like that because they would tell me say
Phil you're not a kid it bastard it's
that I think it's them respecting the
fact that being mr. Olympia is very very
difficult
like does even want more of this on his
plate but you do want it but so
therefore why would they them out of
respect for me why would they come up to
me and say hey Phil we know that you
have 365 days of Hell going to Jim be in
the advance word you know doing all the
stuff we want you to do these
commercials we want you to do all this
other stuff we wanted you to do this
handshake tours you're saying this
everybody is not like that
in our industry I am I the conversation
I hope the right people watch this [ __ ]
we need to continue this conversation in
a private setting can kind of see what
we can do with well I think you know for
anyone watching and they're you know
have a interest in this industry I just
listed a ton of different ways of how
they can
make joint venture with pro organization
with its athletes as well whether it be
a Sony Samsung whatever you know like to
put up the LEDs that are events and
stuff like that I mean there's commerce
everywhere but to utilize our athletes
in a positive light I think it's easy I
think you just have to spend time with
them like what we're doing here they
just have to spend time and uncover some
some history of why they wanted to get
into this at all so then the public will
see this guy just trying to be for the
monetary just like the the cash grab or
was he really trying to be here for that
and I could say for myself I won the mr.
Olympia last year with no endorsement
from a supplement company I did do that
I proved that you could have certain
hardships in your life no different than
anybody else but I always focused on
being number one and what it takes to be
number one and I think that story can
help out CEO you know a fortune 500
company having a guy coming in and
rallying up the troops to go get out
there and do something I feel like you
can work with at-risk youth I feel like
you could work with young men and women
that are dealing with suicidal thoughts
and tennessee's and stuff because maybe
they're trying to find themselves and
they don't have anybody to talk to and
listen to are you talking about this
like are you blogging or you are you
documenting any process of what you're
doing do you write on a weekly basis
right people do I actually well as far
as like Twitter and stuff I utilize that
no no I'm talking about like compiling
data for like books no no no your
thoughts like here's the thought of the
week by you like yeah by you and here's
what I'm thinking about you know I mean
I'm not sharing that with the world no I
think I didn't want to consider I think
it's I think it's important that I
probably do because obviously people
probably think that well Phil is just
concerned about winning because being
mr. Olympia has to be difficult yeah I'm
at that point in time in my career where
it's all about helping other people and
bringing more positive life light and
realizing that phil is just a regular
dude but yet he's not you know he knows
how to switch it on he's a professional
at what he does but he has other special
interests he wants to help people he
wants to get them in shape he does not
want kids to be able beast he wants to
make sure that there's free or reduced
lunch offered at schools he wants to
work with superintendents and stuff like
that he wants to make sure that kids
have meals
not focusing on and here's something I
gotta say real quick I cannot stand this
school these money they need a new
reader board it's an interesting school
you name it whatever city in the country
they didn't be tracking this and that
you know what they do coca-cola
pepsi-cola come in and they give them
the money you know what they do in
return for the vending machine on every
corner every hallway every floor of
every building you wonder why these kids
ain't paying attention you loaded up
with damn sugar all day they're gonna
crash and burn and now they're not
getting the proper nutrition inside
their own high school and you have open
campus you don't think they're gonna go
somewhere to go find it how often you
talk about this stuff every time I get a
seminar okay so I got a challenge for
you can I can I challenge okay
I'm a fan okay okay you are a true
believer you have one thing that's very
difficult to have you cannot buy it at
Nordstrom's you cannot buy that Neiman
Marcus you cannot buy it on Amazon you
have moral authority you can't buy moral
authority now here's a challenge with
some people with moral authority when
you have moral authority
if you don't voice your thoughts on a
weekly basis somewhere that can be
shareable to other people not an
audience of a thousand or five thousand
that's too small if you don't share that
and I read it at 12 o'clock at night
like you know what I agree with this guy
let me post on my facebook let me post
on my Twitter let me email animate text
it to my guy and then obviously got 50
readers 500 readers thousand readers
100,000 breeders 300 thousand readers
one thing gets in hand of somebody at
the DC and they say we want to meet with
you and you get a call to come in my
challenge to you as a friend as a fan
would be you know you and your girl your
discipline guy she does your diet I
heard how disciplined she is with the
cooking and all the stuff that you guys
do together so like a team thing you
have once a week whatever you rant about
if she pays attention to it says baby
talk about this write about this this
week in just three paragraphs start
writing every week document it on your
site let me come and see it and read it
do it on your Instagram post a short
video whatever it is because I think
that the the part where Arnold got him
to get to the point where he was at he
shared those thoughts and he meant evil
right now look what he's doing he's not
the president he's done any calls at the
present all the time and so he's getting
that attention from listening to you
just sit here listening to you all I'm
thinking about is I don't
enough people know about that you know
there are more people order nobody who
are not in your world for sure so who
are not in and like what you just said
right now coca-cola Pepsi and bending
machine everyone we're wondering why
they're crashing I'm singing I'm
probably gonna use that another
conversation when I go back you just so
next week I'm gonna be sitting with
somebody I'm gonna say you know last
week I was talking to Phil Matier what
philosophical top line and what do you
with them what do you think about this
thousand people eight thousand seventeen
thousand people let me contact Phil no
for sure and so you're you're a smart
guy you're a brilliant guy you're seem
like a guy that's close to the
perfectionist I'd no one's perfect but
you're a perfectionist type of guy and I
think you're not gonna just say anything
out of your mouth without some weight
behind it no that's a give be very
interesting to listen to by the way I
appreciate that
my impression I've listened and watched
a lot of your stuff but coming in here
walking away from you dude this industry
is lucky to have you and I just hope
this thing gets to whole different level
where the flag theory can spread this
message to other people to realize how
much this has bled into Hollywood this
is bled into sports this has bled into
media and we got to bring that attention
back to how it got started back in yeah
it's it's got to come back and I
appreciate that and obviously the
dialogue and stuff and I hope everybody
watching was able to get a different
glimpse of who mr. Lippe is my headstone
will not read mr. Olympia my headstone
will read my name Phil Heath that's it
but it's now time to like you said share
this information have more dialogue use
the resources that we have through
social media and get the voice out there
and in our industry spit out the
knowledge recognize how it's we've
shared our knowledge and bring it back
bring that energy back into us you know
I appreciate the time brother this was
always I mean listen here's what here's
what we got to do here's what we got to
do you got to go follow Phil he on
Instagram filled you have a website is
it Phil Heath calm please Philip it's
the government named Philip Philip two
L's pH I del L I Phe ATH doc is there a
way to subscribe to a newsletter there
or yeah a newsletter and I also have a
new app that's coming out it's called
the fit app it stands for Phil Heath
instructional training
so fit a pH IT yappi IT got it yep so
you get it's always fit now so pH IT in
o W if it already out already yeah oh so
they can go down one and they'll be able
to see it on Instagram it's just at a pH
IT underscore a PP here's what I would
like to see you do I want you to go
tweet fill and say Twitter fill I'm
looking for your weekly thoughts I want
tweet it yes to him okay I want you to
go defend them and say I want to hear
your weekly thoughts about if they do
that yes and here's the beautiful thing
about that
you guys hit me up on the Twitter you
become a follower and stuff you ask me
something and you say hey sorry
interview loved it hated it whatever
want to see more of you I'm gonna give
it to you I will give it to you it's
when I don't see the participation
because it's got a ways usually goes
both ways so I hope I get to see you
guys you're gonna see that Phil Heath on
Twitter at Phil Heath on Instagram and
it's been a pleasure probably really
enjoyed it thank you so much yes